est ce que vous savez de quoi on parle
normalement oui vous avez vu le lien
vous avez cliqué dessus
ça ça ça c'est énorme ça c'est la boîte
d'un nouvel aspirateur robot de robot
rock est en fait une classe est juste
hyper démentiel
l'exercice aujourd'hui ça va être
d'ouvrir sa de vous expliquer de quoi on
parle c'est le q7 max plus quoi je vous
parle à d'aspirer à thouars connecter si
vous suivez ma chaîne vous savez que je
vous ai déjà parlé plusieurs fois
respiratoires connectés parce que la
collectivité ça passe également par fait
d'avoir une maison connectée et avec ça
on a un truc assez dingue et j'aime bien
vous parler de ce pirate heures
connectés alors il ya plusieurs choses
déjà requis aujourd'hui une vidéo qui
est réalisé en partenariat avec robot
rock pour vous présenter cette nouvelle
petite bâtisse j'aime beaucoup parce que
moi j'ai un aspirateur à la maison robot
rock que j'utilise beaucoup donc enfin
j'utilise oui surtout lui qui bosse tout
seul mais c'est lui qui bossent et ça
c'est cool alors on va regarder ça c'est
de voir bien par la toile
attend les poignets non j'ai la peau du
très bon jeu déployé
voilà
ça c'est lui la voyez ici en fait vous
avez un gros doc qui va venir parler
toute la poussière à la cochonnerie ici
là là dedans ça vous amène jusqu'à cette
semaine son envie d'âge vous montrez
truc l'aspirateur est là alors attendez
c'est le premier run boxing où les
caméras parce qu'on en fait alors vous
montrer donc là on expulse que j'ai donc
ça c'est le bas de la station qui est
pratique on explique qu'il va rentrer là
et là j'ai les eaux du doc ok ça c'est
quoi ensuite ça c'est un sac ensuite
l'aspirateur en lui-même ok on déjà
labrosse qui a fourni installé avec la
grosse brosse en caoutchouc là le
capteur de tous les côtés il ya un
leader aussi sur le dessus qui est un
laser en fait il servira à devenir
cartographier reconnaître votre pièce
donc ça c'est cool qu'est-ce qu'on a
ensuite au dessous 1 place on adopte
aussi on est une petite inquiétude tient
pas là parce qu'il faut danger on n'est
pas sûr que sa charge cécile et puis ça
s'il bloque dans lequel vous allez
mettre votre sac et il va venir
vider toutes vos cochonneries dedans et
ça c'est cool et puis ensuite ça c'est
la brosse que je vais me reposer en
dessous qui va servir pour nettoyer le
sol c'est la serpillière en fait qu'on
va mettre sous l'aspirateur et puis
qu'est-ce qu'on a encore ça c'est les
docks qui vous explique comment ça
marche et vous avez un petit quickstart
guide pour vous montrer un peu comment
ça marche donc l installation de soul à
je dois avoir un tournevis ça vient
comme ça ça ça vient là
sont bien dessus j'ai mon petit truc qui
est là la petite vis et en fait j'ai
envie c'est tout ça là vous voyez il ya
juste des petits bitonio l'avenir vie
c'est dedans histoire que ça bouge pas
et c'est tout une fois que j'ai fait ça
j'ai mon dock qui est prêt à poser au
sol lors j'ai un petit passage de câbles
à faire derrière ça ça vient se brancher
derrière là ça vient faire le tour tous
derrière là ça revient par là et sa voix
dans la prise électrique une fois que
j'ai regardé maddock j'ai tout ce qu'il
me faut
[Musique]
ok alors l'idée du rebord opus est max
plus c'est quoi c'est en fait de vous
allez apporter plus grâce à ce gros donc
là et bien aux plats tout fout l'camp
vous avez cette semaine sans visage sans
vidage pourquoi pas ce que fait votre
aspirateur robot à chaque fois qu'il va
revenir à sa base pour se recharger il
va transférer toutes les cochonneries
qui la lui à l'intérieur et ils vont
remonter ici dans le dock il va pouvoir
les stocker pendant cette semaine ça
vous évite d'avoir à chaque fois enlevé
le bac à les vider à leur remettre
dedans vous embêter plus vous avez
l'esprit tranquille cette femme est quoi
mais devenir programmer votre aspirateur
robot et lorsque vous êtes au travail
vous n'êtes pas là ou quoi que ce soit
et ben lui il fait le boulot tout seul
et vous êtes vraiment pénale pendant
sept semaines donc ça s'est bien passé
il ya un autre point qui est super
intéressant qui dit aspirateur dit
inspiration je pense que là je vous
apprends rien vous avez jusqu'à 4200
pascal d'inspiration alors au delà de la
notion un peu technique du nombre de
pascal que vous allez avoir ce qu'il
faut savoir s'il pouvait lire programmé
sur votre aspirateur robot je vous
montrais l'application dans quelques
instants pour bien choisir quel type
d'expiration vous voulez vous pouvez
choisir soit d'aspirer au maximum pour
vraiment venir tout ramassé tout le
temps et que savoura m'assois zone un
peu plus dur voire vous vous dites
maintien
jour j'aimerais que ça respire un peu
moins fort parce que allez on va y aller
coûte parce qu'on y va de temps en temps
puis un jour par contre sa tartine au
max et quand vous vous le start in à max
savent à tartiner à max jusqu'à 4200
pascal pour tous vous ramassez les
poussières les petits cheveux dans les
coins de portes dans les sites dans les
ca ca va tout aspiré donc ça c'est
pratique il ya un autre truc vachement
intéressant sais pas si vous le savez
pas ce que j'en ai présenté un paquet
d'aspirateurs broc parce que je les aime
beaucoup se trouve vachement intéressant
il ya deux actions principales la
première c'est qu'effectivement ça
aspire c'est pratique ça va venir par là
dessous les votes bros qui tourne à
bruxelles devant qui elle va ramener les
cochonneries ici directement l elle
tourne elle ramasse elle aspire sas
pierre fort et ça a super bien et en
plus de ça vous avez cette petite partie
avec une serpillière que vous allez
mettre dessous donc la serpillière elle
va voir plusieurs bénéfices la première
c'est effectivement ma d'enlever des
petites cochonneries des petites taches
un peu résistante à taches de café et
compagnie ça c'est plutôt pratique
plutôt bien mais le deuxième point qui
est extrêmement intéressant c'est que
pour quelques petites un peu je dirais
des très petites poussières qui vont
rester en surface et bien comme elle l
est humide ça va finir d'enlever et
d'assainir et de clean et votre maison
donc ça c'est très pratique et pour ce
faire qu'est-ce que vous avez devant
vous avez un bac ici à l'intérieur alors
regardez ce bac il est juste là vous
prenez vous enlever ça alors ça c'est
hyper pratique parce que c'est la
première a les crocs broche et ça va
bien je vous montre normalement ici dans
cette partie que vous aviez là vous
aviez uniquement votre bac d'aspiration
ici vous avez bac d'inspiration et en
plus de ça vous avez le petit bac house
qui fait qu'il est vraiment partagé en
deux dans toutes ces parties là on va me
récupérer vos cochonneries qui vont
ensuite être récupérée directement là
vous avez un petit filtre bien
évidemment pour éviter que ça met le
bazar et vous avez juste ici votre petit
bacau donc vous remplissez votre eau par
ici et vous ne vous endettez pas avoir
un deuxième acte parce qu'avant je vois
si vous connaissez un peu l'histoire
vous aviez un deuxième mandat qui
arrivait juste là que vous veniez glissé
vous vous éclipser c'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui tous les directement ici
vous avez juste à prendre votre
aspirateur robot vous prenez et vous
mettez ça et vous avez votre bac à
cochonneries et votre bac à flotte qui
est directement là et c'est extrêmement
pratique je vous le montre ici vous avez
votre petit voyant douifi qui vous
montre que vous êtes connecté au wifi de
la maison vous avez un petit bouton
reset également pour malheureux remettre
à zéro sur le dessus on va retrouver
quoi garder là on va venir retrouver le
bouton pour l'allumer le bouton pour
retourner à la maison et puis là on va
avoir un petit détecteur mouvement
lorsqu'il vient taper up like des taxes
d'état qui détecte et juste à l'avant
ici vous avez votre petit à laser petit
lidar qui va venir lui cartographier
votre maison pour savoir où est-ce qu'il
va donc ça c'est aussi extrêmement
pratique et en plus de ça le q7 max plus
il est équipé d'une pompe électronique
or la pompe électronique elle fait quoi
et balcons frauduleux pompe elle va
venir adapter le débit d'eau au type de
sol que vous avez donc en fonction du
sol que vous allez avoir à la maison la
pompe elle va faire le boulot et vous
avez jusqu'à 240 mètres carrés de
surface de lavage tandis que vous avez
quoi faire avec 30 niveaux de débits
d'eau différents et 300 g de pression
constante au niveau du ballet je vous
parle il ya quelques instants de ce
laser le laser c'est quoi c'est un lidar
qu'est ce qu'il va faire le lidar et
bien va venir cartographier en se
déplaçant à venir cartographier votre
maison alors il le fera lors de son
premier passage dans votre maison mais
ce qui est intéressant ça qui va
reconnaître les pièces il va nous créer
une carte de votre maison aux époux va
revenir vous d'ailleurs ajouter ensuite
les meubles ont des appareils à canapé
d'ayasse il aya ça comme ça vous voulez
vraiment votre maison avec vue du haut
et lui vous voyez à quel endroit il est
passé où le voyez lorsqu'il est passé là
il va passer là vous savez exactement ce
qu'il a fait comme type de nettoyage et
sans le vote directement dans
l'application et une fois de plus nous
l'avons dans quelques instants et si
vous avez une maison avec plusieurs
niveaux il ya pouvoir cartographier
jusqu'à quatre niveaux très facilement
vous le prenez vous le posez hirko des
niveaux tout ira bien et puis vous avez
une programmation personnalisée pour
venir créer des routines mais une fois
de plus ça je vous le monde en quelques
instants dans l'application autre truc
qui est intéressant c'est que si vous
avez une brosse en caoutchouc alors
cette brosse en caoutchouc est toujours
super bien faite de la part de rubrum
parce qu'en fait elle va éviter que vous
allez avoir des petits chevaux qui vont
venir ce concept au début en fait trop
beau qu'ils avaient des espèces de
petites brochettes et souvent des petits
cheveux qui venaient se coincer son tour
ici avec celle là plus de soucis ça
marche bien c'est très pratique si vous
voulez venir enlever quelques petits
trucs qui serait là normalement il n'y a
pas trop de problème et si vous voulez
garder pouvait venir l'enlever
extrêmement facilement et ensuite vous
reposer ça là dedans et c'est parti mon
tintin on est peinard voilà et vous avez
une grosse batterie de 5200 milliampères
heures qui vous donne jusqu'à 3 heures
de nettoyage sur un seul et même
nettoyage alors trois heures en mode
silencieux et sur un sol dur ok mais
franchement ici vous avez de quoi faire
même si vous avez des tapis sol dur et
que vous n'êtes pas tout le temps en
mode silencieux c'était en dessous des 3
heures mais ce qui est sûr c'est que ça
fera taf à moins d'avoir un énorme
château avec un millimètre carré à la
maison mais sinon globalement ça devrait
aller
vous avez une application dans laquelle
vous allez me retrouver ici votre
aspirateur robot le configurer voir tous
vos aspirateur robot alors regardez
c'est l'application robot rock dans
laquelle on va retrouver ici notre robot
aspirateur ici on a le q7 max alors je
clique dessus j'ai pas mal
d'informations directement comme ça je
vois qu'il est en charge va clore mon
dernier nettoyage et nettoyer 30 mètres
carrés le niveau de batterie le temps de
nettoyage passé je vois partout là où il
est passé alors j'ai arrêté pour la démo
pour vous le montrer mais j'ai encore
toute cette zone là qu'ils auraient pu
être faites je vois exactement là où il
est passé et je vois là où et tout de
suite il ici en train de se recharger
grâce à sa caméra lidar le robot via un
scanner votre maison et vous décider
d'un plan de votre maison donc ça c'est
vachement intéressant alors regardez moi
j'ai attribué des pièces ladoire j'ai
une chambre salle de bain la cdc qui les
stimulent plage une très grande pièce
salon salle à manger cuisine alors si je
souhaite je peux venir édité ma carte en
cliquant regardez là juste en haut ici
je vais donc gérer les cartes là j'ai ma
carte je peut la modifier et là je peux
venir dire ben tiens par exemple venir
modifier les pièces si par exemple je
vous dit le coin cuisine ici je vais me
laver davantage venir régulièrement de
faire passer plus et bien je peux
cliquer sur divisé je choisis ensuite ma
zone et ça se disent très facilement je
peux venir ensuite les fusionner si je
le souhaite quand je soulage venir
envoyer mon robot que dans une pièce si
je le souhaite par exemple ceux qui
viennent dans la chambre et bien gardé
je fais ça je sélectionne ma pièce et
puis ensuite je clique sur nettoyer et
lui va directement partir de nettoyer
que cette pièce là et pas une autre donc
ça c'est aussi une vachement vachement
intéressant avec un temps canon de 6 1 6
2 6 3 6 pourrait en venir là nettoyer en
profondeur également pour des zones je
peux dire par exemple est très bien
nettoyer la cuisine en profondeur j'ai
sélectionné ma cuisine qui est comme ça
tac tac tac up pareil je définis tu
viens une fois deux fois trois fois
j'appuie sur nettoyer et lui par
directement voyez par exemple ici je
vois exactement ce qu'il a fait est là
où il est passé donc là je vois qu'il a
eu un petit peu de mal à passer sous la
table ont peut-être qu'il faut qu'ils
viennent enlever des éléments pour
qu'ils puissent passer plus facilement
là on voit mes meubles il a fait le tour
du fauteuil le tour d'une table basse
enfin bref tu peux venir afficher
ensuite si je le souhaite regarder le
nom de la pièce le type de sol et les
meubles faire une rotation de ma carte
et avoir une vue soit en 2d souvent en
3d soit carrément matrix regarder en 3d
up et là vous avez vu bienvenue chez moi
en suisse le dire a ajouté des zones
interdites c'est par exemple un endroit
où je veux pas qu'ils aillent grade et
je clique sur zone interdite jeudi ben
moi il ya un endroit où j'ai pas envie
que tu viennes nettoyer je veux faire un
petit mur un vide regardez je peux bien
sectionné mur invisible zone interdite
ou leurs zones censées appuyer par
exemple ici j'ai un tapis donc là je me
faire une zone sans serpillière donc là
hop là je ne veux pas de serpillière
pour ne pas venir endommagé le tapis ça
ne sert à rien de la même manière une
zone interdite si je veux par exemple
qui ne viennent pas nettoyé maintien par
exemple par ici parce que il ya les
jouets de mon fils et que c'est un peu
le bazar mais regardez j'ai mes petites
sommes donc là il n'ira pas et de la
même manière si à un moment j'ai pas
envie qu'ils aillent dans une pièce je
me fais un petit mur invisible hop là
non mur invisible il est là de même un
petit mur à l'entrée de la pièce hop je
remettrai simon mur et là il pourra pas
rentrer dans la pièce bon moi l'idée si
c'est pas qu'ils viennent pas nettoyer
les pièces donc je viens à l'enlever
mais voyez c'est très facile on peut les
ajouter facilement on peut les supprimer
très facilement donc ça aussi c'est
super vous pouvez venir également
personnaliser vous directement ce que
vous voulez l'édition manuel vous pouvez
aussi réinitialiser votre carte mais
également ensuite régler les différends
un niveau et d'aspiration de silencieux
jusqu'à maximum et pareil pour l'eau un
arrêt de on n'utilise pas d'eau ici
jusqu'à un débit qu'on peut venir
personnalisés ou alors carrément vous le
mettez en extrême directement bon moi ce
que je vous conseille de vous mettre
quand même sur moyen un peu partout ça
suffira largement il ya un truc que je
n'ai pas montré quel super bien c'est
dans la gestion de votre carte vous êtes
là vous sélectionnez votre carte là vous
pouvez lire par exemple modifier les
meubles donc là vous cliquer dessus
hopla modifier le mobilier vous pouvez
rajouter un lit un canapé multiplace je
prends un meuble hop là je le déplace
juste là je viens le positionner je le
fais tourner très facilement et ensuite
je vais venir adapter sa taille voyez
hop là là par exemple je vais mettre un
petit canapé up juste ici la même
manière je peux prendre un lilas ouais
ça c'est ma chambre à coucher donc là
c'est pareil on fait pivoter lit et je
le mette exactement à l'endroit où il
n'a pas pu errer donc là j'ai mon lit
donc voyez comme ça je fais à modifier
mes pièces très très facilement et puis
ensuite le type de sol ici par exemple
c'est du bois dans cette zone ici et ben
c'est également du bois comme ça il
saura exactement ce qu'il ya et ensuite
tu peux choisir par défaut et ça veut
dire tout comme ça il va venir adapté
également en fonction de mon type de sol
j'enregistre je pense venir créer des
séquences assez vachement intéressant je
veux dire tu vas commencer par telle
pièce battue va commencer par ici
ensuite tu vas là tu as là et tu finiras
ici ensuite de la même manière lorsque
je suis ici paraît dans les options g
épinglé et dire par exemple un aux
plaintes tu vas là j'appuie ensuite sur
aléas est lui parti à nettoyer cette
zone là ensuite on met paramètres c'est
pouvoir venir la gérer ma carte
facilement avant les paramètres du robot
voyant des boutons un petit boost sur le
tapis lorsqu'il rencontre un tapis il va
envoyer un peu plus d'inspiration ça je
vous le conseille réellement
l'activation de la sécurité enfant on
verrouille tous les boutons du robot
donc lorsque vous avez un enfant lâché
en liberté chez vous eh bien vous
cliquez là il pourra appuyez sur les
boutons le lancer l'a arrêté et
compagnie lorsque leur zone de charge et
ça ne marchera pas donc ça c'est plutôt
bien après il fonctionnera que
l'application fonctionne que vous aurez
programmée mais si vous êtes le week-end
par exemple avec votre enfant chez vous
ce qui me paraît normal ou le soir chez
vous si vous avez des enfants le général
ils sont quand même avec vous parce
qu'ils vivent avec vous et ça c'est
plutôt bien et bien cette petite
sécurité l'a peut être intéressante moi
je la désactive un mode ne pas déranger
bain par exemple tu vas pas passer
l'aspirateur de 22h à 8h du matin parce
que là je dors et ça m'arrange par les
unités en mètres carrés là on est plutôt
d'accord on va également par une option
sur le paramètre du vidage automatique
du robot alors là le vidage automatique
est activé après vous avez plusieurs
modes un mode intelligent lorsqu'il va
se sélectionner le mode de vie d'âge le
mieux adapté dans votre logement un mode
de vie d'âge léger pour les petits
environnement propre équilibré pour le
rangement de toutes les tailles et puis
max convient pour les grands logements
et les environnements plus sales voilà
quand c'est le bazar on peut bien faire
ça comme ça la voix du robot savoir si
vous le voulez en français en espagnol
en allemand portugais et en italien la
langue que vous voulez bien évidemment
les programmes alors ça les programmes
c'est vachement intéressant parce qu'en
fait vous allez venir ajouter un
programme vous le dites tiens tu va
démarrer on va le dire tu va démarrer à
16h16 et tu va répéter ça tous les jours
par exemple on veut dire tu vas le faire
une seule fois tous les jours tous les
jours la semaine le week-end vous pouvez
carrément venir le personnalisés quel
jour tu vas venir répéter cette scène
époux et crée beaucoup de scènes vous
sélectionnez ensuite les paramètres de
nettoyage la puissance d'aspiration plus
ou moins forte du silencieux un peu
light jusqu'au mode maximum qui lui va
vraiment envoyer envoyé envoyé envoyé
puis pareil pour le débit d'eau vous
envoyer un tout petit peu d'eau vous en
voyez beaucoup d'os est très élevé bref
vous choisissez et c'est vachement
intéressant et ensuite vous choisissez
l'état je voulais qu'ils aillent et
compagnie vous avez également épinglé
allait me tiens tu vas là hop là va
bosser là bas un petit contrôle à
distance avec les boutons
son smartphone vous l'utiliser comme une
télécommande pour venir piloter votre
robot tiens voilà tu te déplaces hop là
c'est parti pour trouver ensuite
l'historique des nettoyages vous avez
l'entretien qui vous dit ben tiens
quelle moins ce qu'il faut venir à
changer les choses voulait nettoyer la
fuite le brosse latérale labrosse
principal les capteurs le sac à
poussière et la serpillière si besoin le
service clientèle le manuel utilisateur
les mises à jour logicielles j'en ai
fait une juste avant donc ça c'est
plutôt bien
[Musique]
ce robot rock q7 nax plus je trouvais
intéressant une fois de plus ça vous
permet d'être tranquilles sans nettoyage
de votre maison si vous êtes vraiment
bien pris si vous avez optimisé
l'histoire vous avez tous programmés
dans votre application vous lui avez dit
elle jour tu ne feras sa tête jour tu
feras s'attelle au jour tu me feras tout
et tu vas y aller à fond vous allez tout
gérer extrêmement facilement il va venir
se vider ici vous avez jusqu'à cette
semaine vous êtes peinard le seul truc à
bien vérifier de temps en temps passez
vous avez quand même suffisamment nous
dans votre réservoir ici pour vous le
verrez très rapidement mais vous avez
vraiment de quoi faire et en fait avec
ça une fois qu'on a compris qu on a géré
qu'on optimise l histoire vous est
peinard il ya une vraie sécurité parce
que lui il va venir au collège cachez
vous donc il va pas tout abîmé il va pas
jeter de tous les côtés vous êtes
extrêmement tranquille et sa solution de
la vigne est une fois de plus vous avez
votre i porting dans votre application
est votre appel vous dira tout nettoyage
terminé il ya siyassa vous êtes
extrêmement peinard si ce robot
aspirateur vous intéresse je vous mets
un lien en bas dans la description pour
tenir l'acheter parce que je trouve
extrêmement intéressant et puis surtout
n'hésitez pas à poser toutes vos
questions ou interrogations directement
en bas en commentaire et puis à vous
abonner parce que on va parler de take
two le temps de plein de choses de pas
notre truc et même de maison connectée
et ça c'est cool allez je vous embrasse
prenez soin de vous il ya très vite ciao
[Musique]